it's very hard to know what to do as a
doctor
I'd say particularly as a primary care
doctor when people come in asking for
pain medications on the one hand you
don't want to not treat someone who's
genuinely in pain and the other hand you
don't want to give someone pain
medications who's not in pain because
then you add to the black-market
of opioids and the person could take it
or sell it and someone could overdose on
the medication so it's a very difficult
situation whenever someone comes in
asking for opiates
I tend to be an awful person to ask for
opiates just because I've suffered from
opiate addiction and a saying in
recovery which is an age-old saying
which is really important is that you
can't [ __ ] a bullshitter and given
that I've employed almost all of the
tactics that drug seeking patients have
employed to try to get drugs out of
their doctor I feel like I have a very
good radar for picking up and perceiving
when patients are trying to scam me for
opiates so I feel like I do a good job
of that but that said there are a lot of
times in the office when is just in the
gray zone when I just can't tell whether
the patients in pain or whether they're
trying to scam me and then I'm faced
with this you know this really unsavory
choice so I want to go home at night and
feel like I was scammed or don't want to
go home at night and feel like I was
this cruel doctor that didn't treat
someone's pain so you just have to
decide if you want to err on the side of
giving to medication too many
medications or err on the side of not
giving enough medications you know it's
interesting I once so much didn't want
to face this dilemma that i prescribed
percocet for a patient that was claiming
he had back pain in a limp but I went to
the trouble to follow him out of the
office and I followed him for like two
blocks because I was just dying to know
whether he's stopped limping when no one
was watching him and from the first
block he limped
a block and a half away he limped but by
two blocks miraculously he was cured and
he completely stopped limping and he was
walking perfectly so I discovered that
he was completely lying to me and
scamming me for opiates so he really
it's hard to tell um and you don't
exactly know what to do but you want to
give people the benefit of the doubt but
opiate addiction is such that if it
causes people to be dishonest and it
affects people are so desperate for the
medication that they'll flat-out lie to
you to get it so you and they're very
convincing because they convinced
themselves because they think they do
need it and they do need it in some
senses because they're addicted so it's
just very hard to know what to do and
the answer is to what do we do is that
we do our best which isn't very good but
all we can do is do our best